hello everyone and welcome to round two
of this year's norway chess uh it's a
game from between yani pognishi and
alireza ferruga as you know jan did not
play his yesterday's game against uh
sergey karjakin uh his flight was
delayed so that game i believe will be
play uh played on a free day
but now this one it's uh it's a really
awesome one it features the greatest
opening of all or some would say the
second greatest opening of all and it
feels like this game is straight out of
our uh well newly finished morphe saga
as it features like i mentioned a very
special opening so this is the
armageddon of course their classical
game ended in a draw it was a fairly
quick rue lopez not much was going on at
some point nipple gained some advantage
but all it is are quickly equalized
and they agreed to uh to a draw by
repeating moves but now this is
armageddon let's check it out really an
awesome one so nipple with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have e5 by
alireza and now nepo doesn't go for
knight to f3 like he did in their
classical match uh he plays f4 yes he
goes for the king's gambit as you might
have assumed judging from the thumbnail
alireza accepts the gambit and now
knight to f3 so what do you play here
we've had this position many times
during our morphe saga and i i often
mentioned that uh g5 was played there
then it was considered the strongest and
it's still considered the strongest by
today's standards but alireza plays
knight to f6 uh and already trying to
take uh niepo out of his uh repertoire
if there is such a thing regarding the
king's gambit we have e5 immediately
challenging this knight and knight to h5
and now this knight is looking rather
weird here but the the plus side is
after nipple plays d4 attacks the f4
pawn the knight from h5 will already be
defending this pawn uh so d6 challenging
this strong center and the queen to e2
now threatening to capture here and open
up a discovery towards the black king uh
and now black could decide to keep the
center closed with d5 but alerza plays d
captures an e5 and now there are a few
games in the database uh we're just
queen captures and if i was played this
delivers check also attacks the knight
here but you will not be winning the
night just queen e7 and uh we will have
a queen trade but nepal doesn't want to
trade queens he plays knight captures on
e5 and now it is uh only as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
and this knight is attacked so what can
alireza do well queen to h4 with check
why not if white allows it with g3 by
nepo played in the true spirit of the
king's gambit and alireza continues uh
just happily going forward knight
captures uh on g3 now nipple doesn't
have time to do any discoveries because
his queen is under attack but also the
rook is attacked here so of course uh h
captures on g3 nepo very happily offers
this rook we have queen captures on h1
and now just the bishop captures an f4
uh without this bishop captures on f4
you could continue with some discoveries
but
there really aren't any that to do any
damage like okay knight the g6 check can
be played but after bishop to e6 it's
really not a lot yes you can pick up the
the the rook on h8 but
i mean okay you won
that rook but the knight will not
be able to get out and black has a very
very active position here so nipple
continues in the true spirit of the
king's gambit bishop captures an f4 we
have to go for rapid development uh and
now alireza also has to start developing
his pieces he has a queen on h1 he won
the exchange but all of his other pieces
are still under starting squares and you
might consider some maybe bishop to be
for check then retreat with bishop to e7
uh just uh you know prevent any any
sneaky chicks but the move alireza plays
uh actually loses the game for him he
plays bishop to e6 and it seems like a
very normal idea especially for an
armageddon game where you have um so
little time on the clock and now okay
you don't have any discoveries the
bishop now is blocking the queen's check
towards the black king
but the
game is lost nevertheless so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this uh well incredibly elusive move uh
that wins the game for nipple while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
well developing a piece and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight to c3 gaining control of the d5
square and now black is just busted uh
uh give you an example if uh well if you
just want to prevent d5 i mean why
wouldn't you you have to first play
knight c3 because here the queen is also
guarding the d5 square so knight to c3
has to be played and now let's say you
play c6 okay you gain control of this
square but now just queen side castles
and where is the black queen going
there's no no square for the black queen
uh all of the squares are covered and
there's just no no good move here
there's really nothing you can do bishop
the g2 is coming and that queen is lost
uh just to give you an example it's a
bishop d6 bishop to g2 and you lose the
queen if you play queen to h2 it kind of
seems like you can play this just bishop
captures on c6 check and we pick up the
black queen so alireza has to try
something else he plays g5 he wants to
uh you know create some discomfort
between white's pieces
but uh nipple not interested he
continues with his plan of d5 so g
captures on f4 d captures on e6 and now
again what canal it is a play here uh if
you just capture the pawn which seems
like you should be able to do uh queen
to c4 and now everything is hanging this
is hanging this is hanging there is not
not much to be done here if you try
something like queen to h6 to guard this
pawn we're just gonna capture on c7 and
now whatever you try let's say queen g7
offer a queen trade queen to c8 to check
king to a7 now we can just castle queen
side we don't really care we're gonna
pick up this pawn next pick up the rook
here and even if the black queen picks
up the knight we can play some like
queen captures and b7 with check king to
f6 and now even knight to e for check
king to g6 uh and now even bishop to d3
so this would be a you know a terrible
terrible attack to face uh for for all
it is uh let's say king h6 now we're
going to play queen to f7 and there's no
defense against rook to h1 that's just
game uh of course if queen to h5 trying
to
trade queens and guard the h1 square not
just queen f6 check queen to g6 and now
rook to h1 will be checkmate so a bit of
a longer variation but just to give you
an idea of how dangerous uh uh f
captures on e6 is so we have bishop to
d6 by alireza and now nepo just castles
queen side you could also start
capturing here with the pawn with the
knight but nipple says nope let's keep
this you know uh
in in in the style of the king's gambit
so here queen back to h6 uh bringing the
queen back to help out with the defense
and now okay threatening some f3 ideas
maybe opening up a discovery towards
nepo's king but just queen to b5 with
check we have knight to c6 blocking and
now knight captures on f7 so not
allowing any any tricks here the black
queen is under attack so queen captures
on e6 and now uh not going for something
like capturing the rook that wouldn't
really do you uh all that good all that
much so bishop the c4 just going for
development everything is development
attacking the queen the bishop also
defends the knight so luckily the queen
can escape with temple queen to e3 check
king to b1 and now queen to c5 offering
a queen trade but never says uh that
will not happen knight captures on d6
with check c captures and now queen
captures on b7 attacking the rook here
so what can you do you can't really save
that rook if you try something like uh
rook here we're just gonna deliver queen
to f7 checkmate so you have to guard
against that as well
uh so queen captures on c4 alireza picks
up the bishop here but now queen
captures an a8 with check knights to d8
otherwise you lose the other rook as
well and now rook to e1 with check king
f7 now comes queen captures on a7 with
check king to g6 and now g captures on
f4 again in the style of morphe just
opening up the the g file for for the
rook uh and here all it is that tries
queen to c5 offers a queen trade and
guards against rook to g1 uh but not
really uh nipple just played rook to g1
check and he was in this position on
move 25 yes and move 25 truly in the
spirit of the king's gambit uh alireza
firuja resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here some of the
um more enjoyable continuations let's
say king to f6 uh we're just going to
deliver knight to e for check and we
pick up the queen so nothing nothing fun
for for black there uh if you try
something like king to h6 we just
deliver queen g7 checking h5 and again
rook to h1 will be checkmate so what's
left is maybe to try and be uh ambitious
with king to h5 but still we're gonna
play rook to h1 check king to g6 and now
even f5 with check queen captures on f5
now rook g1 check uh king's gonna gonna
move to h5 now queen to g7 and again
there's no defense against rook to h1 or
if you try to defend the h1 square then
we just deliver queen to g5 checkmate or
you know pretty much anything just wins
here so it doesn't really matter so
after rook the g1 check alerts are
resigned and uh um uh he loses the the
second uh uh clash in a row uh but it's
actually not that bad because if you
think about it alireza drew magnus uh
the world chair champion in the first
round in classical and now he drew the
world championship challenger in the
second round in classical chess he lost
both of the armageddon games but still
definitely not bad for for his classical
raiding and you know just
his playing style in general
uh so yeah that's uh the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh we're gonna cover
some other games as well uh but uh as
soon as i saw the king's gambit i knew
yes this is the one that we're covering
first so really hope you enjoyed that
one
uh and you keep playing the kings gambit
as you can see you can win uh as much as
you want with it uh so once again hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank david marcus john roberts uh f
lightheart uh
chandragupta and leave soon for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day